[Music]
it's a great honor to be here it's a
great honor to be talking about cities
talking about the future of cities it's
great to be here as a mayor I really do
believe that mayors have the political
position to really change people lives
that'sthat's the place to be and it's
great to be here as the mayor of Rio Rio
is a beautiful city a vibrant place
special place actually you look into a
guide that has the best job in the world
and I really wanted to share you a very
special moment of my life and the
history of the city of Rio and now
ladies and gentlemen the envelope
containing the result
to announce that the games of the 31st
Olympia awarded to the city of Rio de
Cali
[Applause]
okay that's very touching very emotional
but it was not easy to get there
actually was a very hard challenge we
had to beat the European monarchy this
is say juan carlos king of spain we had
to beat the power for japanese with all
their technology we had to be the most
powerful man in the world defending his
own city so it was not easy at all and
actually this last guy here said a
phrase a few years ago that I think fits
perfectly to the situation of real
winning the Olympic bid I mean we really
showed that yes we can and and really
this is the reason I came here tonight I
mean I came here to not just show to
tell you that things can be done that
you don't have always to be rich or
powerful to get things on the way that
cities are a great challenge it's a
difficult task to deal with cities but
with some original ways of getting
things done with some basic Commandments
you can really get cities to be a great
great place to live I want you all to
imagine real I mean you probably fool
thing about a city full of energy a
vibrant city full of green and nobody
showed that better than carlos saldanha
last year's Rio
[Music]
this is incredible
[Applause]
[Music]
okay some parts of real are pretty much
like that but it's not like that
everywhere we like every big city in the
world we got lots of people pollution
cars concrete lots of concrete these
pictures I'm showing here there are some
pictures from module 8 it's like the
heart of the suburb in Rio and I want to
use an example of real that we do in
Madrid in this region to see what we
should think it's our first commandment
so every time you see a concrete jungle
like that what you got to do is find
open spaces if you don't have open
spaces you got to go there in open
spaces so go inside this open spaces and
make that people can get inside can use
that spaces this is going to be the
third largest park in Rio I joined this
year it's going to be a place where
people can meet where you can put nature
the temperature is going to drop to
three degrees centigrade so the first
commandment I want to leave you tonight
is city of the future has to be
environmentally friendly every time you
think of a city you got a fing green you
got a fing green and green so moving to
our second commandment that I wanted to
show you let's think that the cities are
made of people I mean lots of people
together cities are packed with people
so how do you do you move these people
around when you have 3.5 billion people
living in cities by 2050 it's gonna be
60 million people so every time you
think about moving these people around
you think about high-capacity
transportation but there is a problem
high-capacity transportation means
spending lots and lots of money so what
I'm going to show here is something that
was already presented in Ted by the
former mayor of Curitiba you created
that a city in Brazil
Jamelia and it's something that we're
doing again lots in Rio it's the BRT the
bus rapid transit so you get a bus the
simple bus that everybody knows you
transform it inside as a train car you
separate lanes dedicated lanes the
contractors they don't like that you
don't have to dig deep down on the
ground you can build nice stations this
is actually a station that we're doing
real
you don't have to dig deep down on the
ground to make a station like that the
station you have the same comfort the
same features as a subway station the
kilometer of these costs a tenth of a
subway so spending much less money and
doing it much faster you can really
change the way people move this is a map
of Rio all the lines the color lines you
see there it's our high-capacity
transportation network in this present
time today we only carry eighteen
percent of our population in
high-capacity transportation with the
BRT s we are doing again cheapest and
fastest way we're going to move to 63%
of the population being carried by
high-capacity transportation so remember
what I said you don't always have to be
rich or powerful to get things done you
can find the regional ways to get things
done so the second commandment I want to
leave here tonight is a city of the
future has to deal with mobility and
integration of its people moving to the
third commandment and this is the most
controversial one has to do with the
favelas the slums whatever you call it
there are different names all over the
world but at the point we want to make
your tinnitus favelas are not always a
problem
I mean favelas can sometimes really be a
solution if you deal with them if you
put public policy inside the favelas let
me just show a map of Rio ghin Rio has
six point three million inhabitants
more than 20% 1.4 million live in the
favelas all these red spots are favelas
so you see they're spread all over the
city this is a typical view of a favela
in Rio I mean you see the contrast
between the rich and poor so I want to
make two points here tonight about
favelas the first one is you can change
from what I call a visual circle to a
virtual circle but what you got to do to
get that is you got to go inside the
favelas bring in the basic services
mainly education and health with high
quality I'm gonna give fast example here
this was an old building in a favela in
Rio culinary denominator that we just
for me to a primary school I mean with
high quality this is a primary assistant
in health that we build inside a favela
again with high quality we call it
family clinic so the first point is that
bring basic services inside the favelas
with high quality the second point I
want to make about the favelas is you
gotta open spaces in the favela bring
infrastructure to the favelas to the
slums wherever you are
I mean Rio has the aim by 2022 by volt
its favelas completely urbanized another
example this was completely packed with
house and then we built this what we
call a knowledge square this is a place
with high technology where the kids that
live in a poor house next to this place
can go inside and have access to all
technology we even built a theater there
3d movie and this is the kind of change
you can get for that so then by the end
of the day you get something better than
a TED Prize which is this great laugh
from a kid that live in the favela
so the third commandment I want to live
here tonight is a city of the future has
to be socially integrated you cannot
deal with the city if it's not socially
integrated but moving to our fourth
commandment
I really wouldn't be here tonight I mean
between November and may 3 is completely
packed we just had last week Carnaval it
was great it was lots of fun we have New
Year's Eve it's like 2 million people in
Copacabana beach we have problems I mean
we find floods tropical rains at this
time of the year you can imagine how
people get happy with me watching these
kind of scenes we have problems with the
tropical rain almost every year we have
this landslides which are terrible but
the reason I could come here is because
of that this was something that we did
that with IBM that's a little bit more
than a year old it's what we call the
operation center of Rio and I wanted to
show that I can govern my city using
technology from here from Long Beach so
I got here last night and I know
everything we got to speak now to the
operation center this is oh sorry Oh his
Secretary of Urban Affairs
so it's all good to be there with you
I've already told it to people that we
have tropical rain this time of the year
so how's the weather areal now weather
radar you see just a little bit of
moisture around the city absolutely no
problem in the cheating terms of weather
today and in the next few days okay
how's the traffic I mean with this time
of year again lots of traffic jam people
get married the mayor so how is the
traffic tonight you see the streets are
clear now it's 11 p.m. in Rio with
nothing of concern in terms of traffic
over to you now the incidence of the day
we have heavy traffic since early in the
morning and in the afternoon but okay so
you're showing out some public services
these are the cars and you can okay
sorry oh thank you very much it was
great to have you here we're gonna move
so that I can make a conclusion
[Applause]
okay so no files displays no paperwork
no distance 24/7 working so the fourth
commandment I want to share you here
tonight is city of the future has to use
technology to be present I mean I don't
need to be there anymore to know and to
administrate the sea but everything that
I said it tonight are the commandments
are means a ways for us to govern cities
I mean
invest in infrastructure invest in the
green open parks open spaces integrate
socially use technology but by the end
of the day when we talk about cities we
talk about gathering of people and we
cannot see that as a problem that is
fantastic if there's 3.5 billion
now it's gonna be six billion then it's
gonna be ten billion that is great that
means that we're gonna have 10 billion
minds working together ten billion
talents together so a city of the future
I really do believe that it's a city
that cares about its citizens integrate
socially its citizens a city of the
future is a city that can never let
anyone out of this great party which are
cities thank you very much
[Applause]